this is a production of Cornell
University
hopefully I won't break into a
Huron intro bio I used to teach in this
room with Bob turchin I'm going to tell
you today about some recent work that
was done mostly by Robin Johnson who was
a former postdoc in our lab this is part
of a collaborative Grant with Sarah hake
and Ann Sylvester and the bioinformatic
data was all analyzed by a Chi's son
so the question was uh it was the NSF
funded project which we're now in a
renewal hopefully on a Proxima distal
patterning during May's sleep
development and the focus was on how you
basically form a boundary between two
different developmental Fields so in
this case we're working with uh the
liguel and the oracle
which are separating in this case on the
Maize Leaf the distal blade which is
photosynthetic of course and the
proximal sheath which is mostly involved
in supporting the plant
and the Oracle and the legal develop
together this is the epidermally derived
film a fringe of tissue all epidermally
derived and the Oracle is derived from
L1 and L2 layers and it forms a nice
line that separates these two distinct
developmental Fields the blade and the
sheath and they are very much uh
distinct in their differentiation at
adulthood you can easily tell a blade
just from epidermal characteristics from
sheath they have different functions
they're very different in their
structures
so you might ask you know okay my family
asked me who cares about this little
flip
blepo tissue on a leaf it's a film of
tissue who cares well actually it's a
great system to study how boundaries are
formed
and how they're organized between very
distinct developmental fields we know
from lots of other studies that organ
boundaries are often the case where new
axes of growth are initiated so the
question is how do you draw a line on a
leaf to separate these fields what
happens there and what are the
mechanisms that specify these distinct
possible distal Fates
okay so uh going back to the earliest
stages of Proxima distal development it
happens first when the leaf is initiated
in this case there's no legal we can't
really see any difference between the
blade what will be blade and will be
sheath which is really just a really
bottom portion of this leaf
primordium fate mapping tells us that
clearly most of this Leaf is now going
to be blade
but they're initiated from the shade of
glomerostems this is an SCM I did many
years ago of a 14 day old seedling
ripped off all but two of the leaves we
see two leaf primordia and like in most
other studied organisms I think everyone
that's been studied in plants so far
initiation of leaves and Maize
is correlated with a localization of
oxen transport proteins so this is an
image that Robin made from a plant
that's expressing yfp labeled pin one
pin one is an oxen efflux protein so
wherever you see these green lines on
the borders of these cells you can
assume pretty much that oxen is leaving
that cell
and you can see at the initiation point
of the next Leaf which is here there's
accumulation High accumulation of this
pin oxygen efflux protein and we also
also can see a line that serves towards
the middle of the of the
geesh the middle of the ameristam which
will eventually form the vascular trace
the mid vein we can see this clearly on
these well more well-developed P1 and P2
primordia I'll use those terms a lot P
refers to plasticon plasticon is defined
as the length of time between successive
Innovations of a leaf from the meristem
so a P1 Leaf is one leaf from the
meristem P3 is three leaves when the
meristem and so on plastic Crown is a
length of time it they can last a day or
longer so any P3 lead from two different
plants will not be at the exact same
stage of development but they'll be
close
okay
this just shows that pin one
we can infer the direction of transport
of oxygen at the site of leaf initiation
by looking at where these uh this pin
proteins are localizing in the epidermis
and we think it's moving down towards
where the leaf will initiate
now the legal is derived completely from
the epidermal layer and this is uh
basically work that was uh
first described in this detail by Anne
Sylvester others like Charmin and people
before him
did a great job describing legal
initiation
I always tell my students if you want to
learn about plant Anatomy maze Anatomy
made morphology look at Charming first
but Ann did a great job looking at uh
these early events in some great detail
and she defined at about the P5 state so
five leads from the meristem there's
this wide band
of localized anticlinal cell divisions
meaning they're in the plane of the
epidermis
if you can see this range of small cells
is forming this wide band we call this
the fat band or the fat line
and later on a little bit later in that
in that plasticon typically
and this in a region of the fat line you
can see a thin line that is emerging by
basically periclinal divisions would
send new growth outside the plane of the
epidermis
and that will become the liquid and the
rest of the development of this is
basically elongation from that of that
thin line from this fat line to form a
fringe and later on a full-blown legal
if you look at pen
this is work that was first described by
Sarah hake in her lab but Robin did this
also in our lab this is a bright field
image basically of a P5 P6 Leaf
primordium probably about P6 we can see
this line here which is the initiating
liguel
and if you look at Pin localization we
can see very clearly nice Stripes of uh
pin localization over the vasculature
that's expected that's in the L2 derived
layer we can see that here
it's internal but also there's a
striking stripe a perpendicular pin
localization which will Mark the
initiating ligule very surprising we can
see that in a cross section here it's in
the epidermis it doesn't connect with
the internal vasculature
so there's some similarities already to
a Lego initiation and leaf initiation
which is a theme of this talk looking at
close close-up issue versions of this
localization we really can't infer any
any One Direction of transport it seems
to be emptying from all sides of all
cells for the most part
no infer Direction
in terms of legal mutations that this
recessment takes to disrupt the ligul
this is work that was done mostly in the
90s and 80s by Mike freeling and Sarah
hakes lab but there are two ones I'll
talk about one is ligamist one which is
important this completely removes
this is messed up removes the ligul and
the Oracle but the line is intact there
should be an image there of uh
close-up of the of belief look at this
too now and so in this case look at this
one removes the ligul but the fat line
is there the boundary is still there
it's a little bit disrupted but it's
made ligamentous 2 is different look at
this too the there's a little patch of
legal in the margins but we can see
there's act there's actually a sheath
that is pushed up where the blades
should be so in this case the fat line
is missing
the boundary is Disturbed
not sure what these are showing this
must be a PC Mac thing
so a legacy 1 and liquidus 2 were both
cloned many years ago they're both
different types of transcription factors
that's not important to us right now but
uh they were cloned in the 90s but
actually Robin was the first person to
ever get a liquidus one in situ
hybridization to work so wherever you
see this purple uh standing right here
that's legitus one transcript
accumulating here's the shoot meristem
it's surrounded by lots and lots of
these tree-like looking a primordia and
we see look at this one first
accumulating at about P6 so after the
fat line is established where the thin
line is emerging where this Fringe is
just starting to grow is where we first
really see it
this is in keeping with uh the phenotype
the fat liners is present the boundary
is there but the thin line is gone
look at this two
is basically expressed throughout the
Chute this is a big surprise we don't
know what it's doing in the shoot
meristem but expressed everywhere but it
seems to only localize okay so let me uh
speed this up so there are also a bunch
of dominant mutants that disrupt
approximate so patterning the first uh
the most famous one is knotted one this
is the picture I got from Sarah it's a
beautiful mutation dominant gain of
function uh most of these which I'll
talk about today are class one knotted
like home mailbox homo domain containing
proteins that's what they encode that
are Mis expressed expressed ectopically
in the wrong place or the wrong
developmental time
and classically what they do is this is
a great example look it's three and
other class one Knox Gene uh it shoves
sheath tissue distally so it places
Blade with sheath when this happens you
have a new blade sheath boundary along
this this axis here and it's hard to see
it here but every time you have this new
abutment of ectopic sheath against blade
we get ectopic ligueles forming so
oligos form with the boundaries between
blade and sheep you can't really see it
because it's mostly a back seal view of
the legal is at axial
but if we were to look at this thing
very closely this is a beautiful
phenotype this is all uh sheath tissue
tissue which is expressing in the blade
mostly over veins and if we saw this on
the opposite side of the leaf we'd see a
little bit of a little flap of legal
every one of those little notches of
sheath
so this phenotype LED Sarah to specify
that perhaps knotted one makes sheath
and she described the expression of the
RNA and the protein many years ago it's
expressed in the shoot meristem not in
leaves it's turned off in leaves we know
now that oxen is responsible for turning
off Knox expression of RNA in the leap
primordium and it remains off the RNA
anyway remains off leaves it's also in
the stem the protein was shown many
years ago by Bill Lucas Dave Jackson and
Sarah to traffic through trash with
Despina so we see uh as opposed to a
knotted RNA which is not in the L1 layer
of the Marist and we see in the L1 layer
the protein and the L1 layer of the of
the meristem but you also see it in the
base of these Leaf primordium we don't
see RNA there
so Sarah thinks this is going to be
pre-sheath the sheath is very much
unelaborated at this stage of
development early on and it elaborates
last last part of the leaf to grow
so that makes sense so she thinks that
uh knotted specifies
sheath
so what did Robin do well she started
with plans and she micro dissected them
and I'll show you how she did that and
we did RNA uh seek analysis of micro
domains which I'll explain a bit she
analyzed the data then we went back to
the planets and looked and where to see
where these genes are expressed and now
we want to actually test some of our
models make mutants and double mutants
and see what's going on
so we used laser micro intersection a
lot of my lab and what she did was she
said okay let's go to a p7 leap where we
can clearly see the legal is just
emerging and she took three sections
each one 100 microns tall
a pre-legular emerging legal pre-sheath
and pre-blade and she left about 50
microns in between to make sure there
was no contamination
and this is a close-up of what our laser
micro dissection scope can do we target
this tissue here this is a thin section
of a shoot Apex it's placed on a slide
these are ugly images there's no
staining there's no cover slip we can
still see if we can see if we can get it
we can see the emerging legal and we can
blast this now off the slide into our
collection tube make RNA do rna-seq and
she did this analysis
reads which map uniquely the mace genome
is duplicated if they're unresolved
parallots we couldn't tell which one it
was we threw it out
okay so this is basically how we compare
the data I'm not going to show the the
Gory
Venn diagrams
but there are lots of genes which are
differentially expressed in these
three-way comparisons of legal versus
sheath legal versus blading Blade versus
two I'm going to talk mostly today about
the genes that are upregulated in the
legal and there are a lot of them
so as a control we looked at look at
this one we know we knew from the
institution from earlier data that it
was expressed highly in the legal and
this RNA seek data confirms this
basically not in the sheath or blade
very significantly up regulated in the
legal so we trusted the data we think
laser micro dissection works
so what kind of genes are they
well the gene that was the most highly
difference expressed in the legal
over a hundred and eight fold versus
illegal 50-fold versus the blade was
this Gene about known function
but it's a grass specific as we so far
as we can tell Gene we don't find
punitive orthologies of this Gene
outside the grasses
suggesting that maybe the legal it
really is a grass specific
sort of a structure
and it's expressed basically a little
bit late P6 recommend The Fringe is
starting to form and later on it
localizes to this Notch this boundary
between the emerging molecule and the
blade and even later on it's clearly in
that Notch between the legal and the
blade
a beautiful and Powerful expression
but the surprising thing was we also
found this Gene was expressed at
multiple organ boundaries so this is the
close-up of the pseudohypical meristem
this is a actually a patchwork of
several and situ photographs that Robin
made and we see it's expressed at the
boundaries of lots of lateral organs
between this incipient leaf primordium
and the meristem between this leaf
primordium and the meristem or the Chute
between this lateral bud
so it looks like it's expressed multiple
organ boundaries
This Grass specific Gene and this was
basically a theme throughout this
analysis one of the genes we found was
cuck two homologous two a gene and
arabidopsis which is a member of a
lateral organ boundary Gene family
expressed organ boundaries so it's it's
expressed clearly in this cleft between
the emerging liguel in PA primordia and
the blade at the boundary between the
legal and the and the leaf but it's also
expressed that boundaries between Leaf
primordia between lateral blood
primordia
it's everywhere
so it looks like legal genes are
boundary genes
here's another example uh this is a a
gene called Bop 4. this is clearly
analogous to probably the ortholog
keep doing that of a gene from barley
which is a Unicom or a branching mutant
they fail to make tillers or branches
they're also legulus
it's expressed highly in the liguel
shown here but it's also expressed in
these lateral buds these will give rise
to ears and Maize
give rise to tillers and barley
so it's a branch primordia Gene
we also found two bell-like home mailbox
genes which caught our eye Bell homilbox
genes interact with class one nox genes
but know that knotted one look at this
three is there enough to make a ligul
develop
and the appear to have to interact with
these bell-like genes
so we our eye was caught by
these two genes Bell 12 and Bell 14. and
again they're expressed nicely in the
ligules in this Notch here and also in
the developing legal itself but also in
the boundaries around the ligul not
maybe the Oracle that's what that
marking but also lots of other organ
boundaries
legals and organ boundaries is a theme
here's another one just to drive this
home Bell 14. it's expressed in a much
wider region it's in the legal Notch but
it's also in the region around the
legion not localized to the ligular Orca
region at all especially early on
but it's also expressed that multiple
lateral organs and their boundaries
so what are they interacting with an
elliptical we know knotted one is not
expressed in the legal region but look
at this three is
so we're doing experiments now to see
whether or not these bells can
physically interact and direct gene
expression by binding with ligamist 3
protein
it's expressed higher up in the legal
Robin showed this as you see again was
the first person to get a ligamist 3 and
situ to work
and it's upregulated and added mutant
leaves so this is a good candidate for
interacting with bells way above the uh
the boundary
it was a big surprise to me Robin showed
me the status that there's a wax
transcription Factor that's the most
difference Express transcription factor
in the ligue
and it's caught my eye because I've been
working on a pair of wax jeans for the
last 20 years
sheet too I asked who is this narrow
sheath and actually it is and I was
totally surprised because we described
this as a gene which functions in the
shoot meristem to specify a leaf domain
so this is a narrow sheath one narrow
sheet to a mutant
which is missing a big chunk of leaf
and this is made early in the maristat
there's a lot of legal missing if you
look at the close-up of this uh blade
sheath found there's a lot of legal
missing compared to Wild Side but we
figured okay if you don't make Leaf
early you can't make a legal on that
leaf later
so I never expected this thing would be
expressed in the legal
we described it as being expressed in
this in the marathon this is a cross
section of the pseudopical meristem this
is where narrative is expressed to
direct those lateral domains
so we find Leaf initiation genes which
are redeployed re-initiated at the uh at
the primordium to make a legal
here's another example a gene called
fabulos of one first described in
robidopsis as being involved in Dorsey
ventral patterning at axial or top layer
patterning of leaves
if expressed in a studio epical meristem
is expressed in leave primordial
throughout the vasculature
in the protozo's island in the xylem
which is at axial but it's also highly
expressed in the legal so another Leaf
initiation Gene which is redeployed at
the legal
so the overall theme Here is that legal
genes are organ initiation and Boundary
genes Branch genes and leap genes which
are redeployed later
and we didn't expect this uh we probably
it makes perfect sense now
but uh we didn't expect this uh it makes
sense because we know that evolution is
pretty conservative
it's not really good at making brand new
structures
it usually takes and borrows mechanisms
and processes from other other events
and modifies them slightly
so here's basically the model it's the
crazy model we actually form this model
by drawing all over Sarah Hicks walls in
her living room uh during a meeting we
had
this is the final version it's
complicated but basically okay legal
initiation reiterates lateral
organizations but it's not completely
reiterated if you look for existence for
example at the uh localization of pen
protein
it connects to the vasculature
in Elite primordium it doesn't connect
to the basket mature analygo these
legals in Maize anyway are not
vascularized
so the idea is that there's a center
action between nox proteins
and oxen oxen is repressed by Knox
proteins these boundary genes like Cox
are repressed by a pin bioxin
and so not as localized to the base of
the leaf we get these Stripes of if you
look at it in this in this transfer
section G's to see here's pin
localization auxin which is removing the
nox
and it's also removing the cuts
and they form this boundary where this
pin is formed and this is where the Lego
will initiate
and we think that these bowels interact
with some nox proteins in this region
here which will form the Oracle and the
ligul
so that's the model uh we hope we can
get refunded and we can test some of
these uh predictions and test this model
we're sure it's not exactly right and
thanks I'll take some questions
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu